hey guys it is Thursday which means news
is on its way from me to you imminently
my name is Jeff this is GS me sony has
confirmed that a blood-borne expansion
is coming the popular action RPG
developed by from software shifted over
a million copies last month and Sony
seem to have taken consumer interest
pretty seriously given they plan to
expand the game president of Sony
Computer Entertainment worldwide studios
Shuhei Yoshida announced have been used
by a Twitter saying I have been asked by
many people if we're making VLC for
blood-borne I can say an expansion is
coming more info later this year colon d
or is it more popularly known grinning
face today is the day after yesterday
and yesterday I told you we'd be hearing
all about the new need for speed game
today well we did and here's everything
I could tell you about that developer
ghost games has announced what they're
calling a full reboot of the racing
series due to arrive on xbox one ps4 and
PC in this fall or autumn if you like
the studio has released in 8 30 second
teaser trailer to get you in gear for
the title and as you'd expect the cars
look pretty and the hip hop is already
kicking off the game will be open world
and is set to feature a day/night cycle
ghosts have said it inspired by NFS
underground and will feature quote deep
customization and immersive narrative
and car culture via a partnership with
EA speedhunters as we've suspected ghost
exact Marcus Nilsson explained that this
time around they're going to put a big
emphasis on story development and they
plan to expand upon the seamless online
integration features from rivals finally
said approach will come out to address
concerns at the witcher 3 suffered a
graphical downgrade speaking to
Eurogamer co-founder martin events key
explained that if the company was only
developing for pc it could have been
better graphically but conversely the
company wouldn't have made enough money
to produce the game in the first place
when questioned about why the game's
graphics
better in the vgx awards show trailer
from two years ago Oh svenska explained
that the demo video was built to run in
as high fidelity as possible and wasn't
weighed down by the games full open
world he said of the subsequent
downgrade quote this is the nature of
games development adding maybe we
shouldn't have shown that trailer I
don't know he insists that approach
never set out to mislead anyone with
footage let me know if you think the
graphical downgrade from the trailer is
a problem or not and fly you can add
against part where we've got information
on the later to which three patches and
the 90-minute Xbox III show that is
everything that I have for you today but
do remember that tomorrow I've got my
top five stories of the whole gaming
week ready to go so I'll catch again
then